today we are playing among us with one
hundred players look at there's so many
people oh my goodness i can't i don't
even know where i'm at on the screen we
have 100 players here and me and chris
are the cops let's do it carl and
chandler are the imposters and me and
chris have to try to kill them but me
and chris don't know what their
usernames are i'm cyan your mom carl
chandler go to your own call let's go
we are trying to find carl and chandler
before they kill everyone server begin
oh my god jimmy's already walking
towards us chris where are you i am by
security there's a hundred people
there's no way we're gonna know who it
is dude there's so many people
everywhere oh
bro electrical is lit
ready oh you got it already dude they
don't even notice even if i knew who it
was he could just walk into a sea of
people and i'd lose him all right
i got one in storage there's a devotee
all right so they were here t-series is
looking kind of sus
all right he's not so every minute i can
check if someone's imposter and because
there's a hundred players i'm gonna
write him down so i don't forget
chris we've cleared two of a hundred
people
we're getting gains i have to wait 23
seconds why is the cooldown so long i
know i still have 25 seconds until chris
chris there's another body i think
there's a lot of bodies everywhere jimmy
to be fair taco bell just stomped on
that dead body yeah taco felt flawless
these two people right here
they're not moving carl your ex is right
on me it's one of them i'm gonna have to
wait 60 seconds if kfc's not the
imposter this is gonna suck chris
there's two afk people down here
okay it's not kfc right kfc is clear
jimmy you need to keep killing like if
they're not he's on me he's literally in
front of me oh my god really i am dumb
it's looking kind of dumb sus
suss
all right it's not i am dumb he's in the
hallway of coms now tell me when he
comes to the cafeteria i still see him i
still see him he's just sitting there
we've cleared four people i wonder how
many people carl and chandler have
killed i'm killing a lot of people
cafeteria okay he moved he's going that
way he's going i can't i i can't tell oh
he went to cafeteria he went to
cafeteria why are there so many dead
bodies here have they just been
slaughtering people in the cafeteria i'm
gonna sit security that's where i'm
going i got a plan i'm just gonna stand
on this stack of bodies and wait for
them to come by and get a kill because
eventually they'll have to kill these
people and then i'll know who it is i'm
big brain in it yo somebody's on the
stack i saw i saw i saw they're trying
to bait they're trying to bait chris
thinks he's slick look at how slow meme
lord is moving away from me that's kind
of sus if he wasn't suss he would have
just left
i killed honk i killed hunk no me more
tying something nope meme lord's not
hiding something i'm killing a lot of
people dude i'm killing like a lot a lot
of people be careful i'm in admin right
now oh my gosh 25 people are dead are no
way wait we can wait for that counter to
go up and we'll know when they kill
someone if your cooldown is up you
should be killing
so like if you turn around and run away
they're gonna know 27 they just killed
two people
it might also go up as someone
disconnect so we got to keep that in
mind i'm killing so many people i keep
running away and killing no don't do it
they're on right side they're on right
oh this is sus why are you standing here
why are you standing here
it's not red karma your ex is right in
front of navigation i'm nervous 35
people are dead chris what are we doing
oh i just killed right in front of one
of them but they didn't see me yo
there's a body down here i told you i
told you they were down here i was
probably looking at them i think there's
bodies everywhere jimmy i don't think
it's just down there
i just called honking reactor
chris wait a minute if you stand close
to a wall you can see another room oh my
gosh i might be able to catch them out
why is dicaprio just hanging out near us
oh he's in cafeteria he's in cafeteria i
hate how many dead bodies are up here
he's going to the left to the left to
the left he went to the left okay i
think he saw me i think he saw me i
think he saw me i haven't seen this
green bat the whole game yep you saw me
you saw me you saw me you saw me you saw
me you saw me you saw me oh yep he's on
you dude yeah i think it's bad to be
honest i haven't seen kfc all game
either
he told me for sure
frick
chris i want you to know i killed
somebody right in front of you i
literally just said to jimmy i'm gonna
start going after people i haven't seen
the whole game and i was like i haven't
seen green bat the entire game one
imposter down yeah it doesn't matter how
we did it we still did it 43 people are
dead 57 remain and one of them is
chandler carl you couldn't even kill
half the people before you got out yeah
you suck i've been killing a lot
oh i got chandler no way that was a
random guess
what i was near you guys so much chris i
saw you so many times what do you mean
you gotta factor in that we're stupid
chandler we deserve a rematch carl
chandler we destroyed you you didn't
even kill half the people how about we
switch easy this is gonna be easy that
is impossible we're gonna lose oh wait
win we're gonna win let's switch sides
carl chris yeah yeah we are now
imposters and chandler is the cop oh we
got this in the bag instead of 2v2 it is
3v1 and because the imposters kept
getting slapped we made the one cop
chandler
to give us an even better chance
i can't tell where any of them are
server i don't know about you but i
wouldn't mind if you open the door and
start the game
thank you sir i killed somebody when i
started oh game started
who's joe rogan who's strong that's me
oh i almost killed someone in front of
trailer chandler's i had electrical i
think i think they ran up back up hey
hey guys guys we need strategy oh dead
body up here taylor just walked past me
are you negative 2 000 iq jimmy yeah i
am double kill here double kill here
double kill double kill
dang it this is so hard and i have a 60
second cooldown i'm hiding in a bunch of
bodies and i'm just gonna kill someone
all right
guys we need call-outs where's shayla um
i haven't seen him i know he was right
there he was right there
he was following me
hey circle me up block me um i'm not
seeing anything security except for a
dead body
hey hey guys i'm sorry but i just killed
your mom what the honk bro chandler's at
the south oh oh no he knows it's us
because we're so fast all right i'm
killing this guy i'm killing this guy
goodbye drive-by come here boomer i know
you saw that mover sorry
it's carl
oh i wanted to kill carl that's my
favorite thing come on there's no one
running by there's already 44 dead we've
already killed 46 people and chandler
hasn't found a single one of us i gotta
start trying people man
oh you are sus mr wasn't me wait wait
wait wait chandler is at admin who's
trying to catch somebody everyone on him
follow me i'm getting brave bream's
running from me come here
there's a guy named i am mr beast but
i'm mr beast kill him
oh yeah you took my kill i was hunting
him
not sus well now you're even less less
because you're dead everyone stay with
me wait chandler is heading towards
cafeteria they can't kill us if we're
all together i'm following chandler
following these people wait tell me
where he is where is he if we're in
cafeteria he's following wasn't me
should i get inside of this stack and
kill somebody
well did you see how i just ran
backwards and he didn't suspect me
i just killed somebody right in front of
him no chance he saw it no chance he saw
it oh my gosh there's not a lot of
people left no
guys all right we've killed over half
the players 45 remain oh wait oh there's
another negative 2000 iq i need to
follow this guy as a cover-up i haven't
seen another joe rogan hello there nope
oh it's marine it's bream okay we got
one of them all right he's he's an
electrical he's an electrical boom oh oh
he can vent right to me stay right here
wait for this cool down oh oh i i just
tried to kill you joe
oh why'd you try to kill him i didn't
see the red you're on a murdering spree
jimmy calm down yeah buddy i don't know
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god he's coming for me
he's got
he's coming for me he's coming for me
i'm gonna go hide somewhere because he
knows it's me
all right he's chasing me he's chasing
me he's chasing oh how did i die knew it
got one you're next buddy ah he knows
his face knows me how did you know it
was me because it's goat joe rogan and
breem am i right i don't know okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna keep rooting them on
joe rogan they know it's you joe rogan
they know it's you keep getting kills
joe rogan they know it's you there's
only four players left i'm gonna train
him on the left side i'm gonna zombie
train i'm killing the people following
you guys there's only three people or
there's only two people left i just
killed one of them
oh oh no no no i got stuck i got stuck i
get stuck oh there's only one person
left chris one person left where is he
i'm going up near admin
okay i lost him he knows joe rogan is
the killer he thinks the other one is
somebody named brime he doesn't know
it's jimmy where are they
they're just hiding from me there's only
one person left yeah i'm trying to find
him i'm trying to find i'm checking
everywhere dude i've literally searched
every room i think he's following
chandler maybe well then we just need to
run up and kill the person we would oh
there you are die wait a minute chris i
don't see anyone he just killed me but i
don't see anybody either i think we i
think we won we killed everyone we
killed all 100 players no you haven't no
you haven't no you haven't
carl and chris we got the dub chandler
we're sorry but we killed everyone that
was really close though actually it came
down to the wire this is just the
beginning we have so much more crazy
stuff coming out subscribe if you're not
already and comment what you want us to
do next and among us we can do anything